remember that a contract is an agreement
between our data model and our views
describing how information is stored it
contains constant strings to represent
all the fields at our user interface
we'll display and in the case of
sunshine that our database will store
we've just covered all the columns that
we'll need to use in our to SQLite
databases that will store weather and
information now let's learn how these
column name constraints are declared in
our weather contract let's take a quick
look at the weather contract class file
that we've given you the contract class
has two inner classes weather entry and
location entry each of these inner
classes contains constant strings that
define tables right now we only have
column constants for weather entry the
table that contains weather forecast
information the first constant is the
table name which for the weather entry
is simply the word weather the constant
values we define in the weather entry
class match the values we're storing in
the weather table for example we've got
minimum temperature which defined here
is column min temp pressure columns to
find its column pressure but we're
missing a column to define the unique ID
this is because we're implementing the
class-based columns which contains a
constant called underscore ID by adding
an underscore ID column to our table as
a primary key we can utilize various
Android helper classes that rely on the
underscore ID column being created the
Lok key column is the foreign key we
talked about earlier that points to
records in the location table since the
column names don't actually contain data
types it's useful to annotate these
types in the variable names and/or
comments to make our contract more
explicit